i do want to take a quick look at the
david pakman show
subreddit uh find it at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t now more than 31
000 of you subscribed to the subreddit
here is a post that i find interesting
and it's called
sometimes i fear being judged for not
wearing a mask after being fully
vaccinated
uh and this uh viewer says right now in
california june 15th the mask mandate is
going away and i'm personally pretty
excited for it i was fully vaccinated in
march got my first dose in february
when i randomly got a text saying my
local vaccination clinic had spare doses
i immediately lined up
i've been seeing a lot of comments on
left youtube videos and subreddits
saying what the cdc did was stupid
or we should keep wearing masks forever
because they prevent the flu
and that kind of worries me not that i'm
judging anyone for continuing to wear a
mask but that people might decide to
yell at me or judge me for not wearing
one at a grocery store without a mandate
once the california mass mandate is gone
i've heard stories in san francisco of
people getting harassed outdoors for
not wearing a mask even though it's been
months since the cdc and california
government said it was okay
do you think people will end up judging
me or seeing me as a republican if i
stop wearing a mask indoors once the
california mandate is gone
yeah i mean the truth is some people
will and
there's going to be a readjustment
period and
i think that people essentially just
have to decide
what is more important to you is the
belief and
understanding that the cdc guidelines
for vaccinated people
feel okay to you uh more important
than the fact that a couple of people
might give you a dirty look because
you're not
wearing a mask and it's just a very
personal decision
as i've said before i think it's great
to have the possibility of wearing a
mask and for it to be normalized
during flu season and particularly if
not only
if if in november it starts looking like
we're having a heavy flu season
against which i will be vaccinated i get
my flu vaccine and covet cases start
going up
i will be glad to when i go i mean
the real place i'm thinking of is the
grocery store or public transit
i'll be glad to go back to wearing a
mask i think that that's a great thing
um that being said right now with cases
so low
with the variants so well controlled by
the vaccine by the uh
by all vaccines i'm comfortable not
wearing a mask
outdoors and when it comes to indoors
just doing what the location requires
and if they don't require
require wearing a mask i'm comfortable
not doing it and
um is anybody judging me probably
probably but i'm completely comfortable
with it it's a very personal thing
and uh i think a lot of it is just
personality driven what what is more
important to you
saying there's no reason for me to wear
a mask based on the medical guidelines
so i'm not going to regardless of the
consequences or i value more
the way that people see me even if it's
random people
um that's a very personal decision that
really only you can make for yourself
another interesting post on the
subreddit asks
how do you guys stay sane i just
finished pacman's show from yesterday
and i've got to say
it's depressing from gridlock in the
senate to trump still having a large
base of support i find myself so
discouraged and turned off by politics
right now
how do you guys keep from being this way
um going on to say later i live and work
in a very conservative area so i'm
inundated with this stuff all the time i
hear really racist homophobic things at
work all the time
how do my fellow liberals in
conservative areas cope the latter part
i can't answer
but i think it is really healthy to
check out from the news
for a few days every single week for
when i'm done producing the friday show
i do not pay attention to the news
unless something
major happens or unless i stumble across
something because i turn the tv on or
look at facebook i am checking out of of
news
for almost three days every week okay
that that's like
almost half the week in a sense i think
it's imperative
i think it's absolutely imperative to
maintain sanity and i would encourage
uh i would encourage people to do it and
then the other thing is
adopt a bit of stoic philosophy
about really understanding what is
within your locus of control and what is
not
because there are always things to be
upset about because so many upsetting
things are happening
but to some degree understanding the
limits can we activate about something
and try to influence a political issue
great let's do it
but understand that you can't control
the outcomes of everything that's
happening and to some degree
we've got to continue living our lives
and make making the best we can of them
so i i think that that would be my
advice but i'm right there with you two
really good posts today
make your own post and maybe it'll make
it onto the show next week
on the subreddit find it davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t during the pandemic and even
at this point
i try to avoid physically visiting a
doctor's office unless i really have to
and that's why i love our sponsor
steady md primary care you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who's a good fit for you
you have a one-hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you any time
by text phone and video chat and
unlike other services this isn't some
random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they can give you
the personal attention you deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss sleep
depression anxiety you don't need
insurance it's just ninety nine dollars
a month with absolutely no other fees or
co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video